[Music]
hey Kelly thanks for having the Arkansas
Symphony Orchestra on your music heals
campaign my name is Drew Ervin and I'm
the concert master of the Arkansas
Symphony Orchestra when we realized that
my orchestra could no longer do live
performances for an audience
we were pretty floored and scared and
shocked and confused but I did what
musicians do we find a place in a way to
make music so the night we cancelled our
very first rehearsal I went online I
posted a little video of me playing
Simba
at nine o'clock
[Music]
and every night since then another
member of my orchestra has had a
beautiful video that posts at nine
o'clock I'm getting to know my own mark
astre and an amazing way where you know
we've got 60 and 90 people on stage but
I'm getting to hear each voice sing and
then getting to hear each person make
music and it's inspired me it's touched
me it's made me laugh you guys ready
let's do it
maybe it's BA maybe it's a pop tune but
it's just a chance for us to get to sing
and for people to count on something
that they can just go for a few minutes
and for those of you watching at home
let's keep this going and let's let
music heal us together
[Music]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going